yesterday a federal judge sentenced
former proud boys leader Enrique Torio
to 22 years in federal prison for the
seditious conspiracy that he supposedly
perpetrated on January 6
th the day of the
on which
torrio not only did not enter the U.S
Capitol but on which he wasn't even in
Washington D.C
nonetheless judge Timothy Kelly said
torio's absence from the alleged
Insurrection to which none of the
supposed insurrectionists brought
weapons quote does not
do anything to detract from the severity
of his conduct
even from many miles away taurio
objected to the certification of the
obviously rigged election and so now the
government is going to imprison him for
more than two decades
Torio did not commit any violent crimes
he's not even accused of committing a
violent crime
he wasn't even in the city
22 years
the average sentence for rape in the
United States is less than 15 years
meaning that Torio faces 50 percent more
jail time than the average rapist but
really he probably faces more than that
because while right-wingers have had the
book thrown at them in recent years most
non-political prisoners don't spend
anywhere near their full sentence Behind
Bars do you know the average time served
by convicted human traffickers in the
United States
less than 10 and a half years
about the time on average served by
child traffickers
16 years
how about the average time served by
murderers in the good old USFA
just 17 and a half years
but the guy who ran the right-wing
drinking Club is getting 22 years for
sending Politically Incorrect texts and
social media posts
is texting out protest messages from a
hotel room really worse than rape human
trafficking child trafficking and murder
objectively no
but subjectively
from the perspective of a regime that is
struggling to maintain legitimacy among
a public that on both sides it's not
just the conservatives on the left too
trusts the system less and less each
year
yes
it's much worse
and our rulers are going to make sure
that it is punished accordingly from
that perspective
tario should count His blessings for the
sentence he got 22 years is pretty rough
but the prosecutions aren't over
and 22 years is a walk in the park
compared to the 700 years that Donald
Trump is facing I'm Michael knowlesis
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by genucel skin care say
goodbye to dark and liver spots bags and
puffiness under the eyes say goodbye to
crow's feet get ready to look as fresh
and sexy as me by going to genucel.com
Knowles we've got some breaking news
coming in from Joy Behar and the view a
Donald Trump caused the flood at Burning
Man we'll get to that in a moment first
though while the ruling party is
arresting and imprisoning the political
dissidents with these huge sentences
for Meandering around the capital on
January 6th often being led in by police
officers sometimes not even being in the
city on January 6th well that's going on
that same
ruling Elite is also preparing to rig
the election by doing kovid again the
exact same thing that they did last time
only here there's a little twist
while Lionsgate is leading Hollywood and
bringing the masks back while Morris
Brown College in Atlanta Rutgers
University well they're beginning to
bring the masks back you're hearing some
talk of more vaccines more masks
goes on CNN and shockingly is grilled by
the CNN host over the failures of his
predictions and the inadequacy of the
public health measures that he was
peddling for for years during covid
Brett Stevens in the times talked about
Cochrane put that on the screen the most
rigorous and comprehensive analysis of
scientific studies conducted on the
efficacy of masks for reducing the
spread of respiratory illness including
covid-19 was published last month its
conclusions said Tom Jefferson the
Oxford epidemiologist who is the lead
author were unambiguous there is just no
evidence that they masks make any
difference he told the journalist Mayan
damasi full stop but wait hold on what
about the n95 masks as opposed to the
lower quality surgical or cloth masks
makes no difference none of it he said
well what about the studies that
initially persuaded policymakers to
impose Mass mandates they were convinced
by non-randomized studies flawed
observational studies how do we get
beyond that finding of that particular
review
yeah but there are other studies Michael
that show at an individual level for
individual when you're talking about the
effect on the epidemic or the pandemic
as a whole the data are less strong
now listen here if we're talking about
stopping the virus then it didn't do
Jack diddly squat but on an individual
level somehow magically they work they
don't work across populations or in
studies or in your fancy science books
but in my feelings for individuals with
the with the magic spells and the witch
doctors then it totally totally works
pretty pretty weak defense to a
devastating report read by a CNN anchor
what's going on here
CNN finally coming clean are they going
to be honest now are they going to give
up the nonsense about covid no no to me
this interaction was similar to that
scene in Star Wars when Darth Vader is
walking on the Death Star and he's
there's that Lieutenant who messes
something up
and Darth Vader says you have failed me
for the last time lieutenant
that's what was going on here
Dr fauci has failed the liberal
establishment for the last time
Dr fauci has no credibility Dr fauci has
become a punchline and perhaps most
importantly Dr fauci is now out of the
government he's no longer politically
necessary for the Liberals he's no
longer politically useful to them he is
a reminder that kovid was predicated on
a bunch of incompetence at best and lies
more likely
Dr fauci has to go
he was useful to the Liberals for a time
but now he's got to go and and they
don't need to prop him up Dr fauci
needed to seem credible he needed to
have the authority of the entire ruling
class while he was running his part of
the NIH no he doesn't now he's they can
hang him out to dry
and they're going to get some new guy in
there but they're going to keep doing
kovid they're they're ramping this up
already and it's a gradual process and
it's right on time covid-19 occurred the
year before 2020 the big election
covid 23 is is showing up right on time
to rig the 2024 election because kovid
was the indispensable necessary
ingredient to change all of the election
rules to open up widespread mail-in
balloting to to open up the prospect of
massive ballot harvesting to do things
that even Barack Obama 10 years ago
admitted open up the system to voter
fraud but it benefited the Democrats to
do it in 2020 it's benefiting the
Democrats to do it now that they're not
giving up
on their Preposterous unfalsifiable
silly arguments they're going to keep
pushing the imminent climate apocalypse
world's going to end in 18 months if you
don't stop driving your truck
they're going to keep pushing the
January 6th the Insurrection myth
they're doing it obviously they're
throwing these guys in prison for
multiple decades
they're just going to be a little
smarter about it and the people who have
lost all of their credibility those guys
are going to be put out to pasture I
really hope that the next guy to come in
and run the covid scam is a diminutive
New Yorker of either Italian or Jewish
background hopefully from Brooklyn or
Queens because I've spent a long time
working on that accent and so I really
hope that I can carry it over but
there's going to be a new guy and it's
going to be the exact same old story
it's going to be the same same type of
voice whether it's got the accent or not
now
this this is the sort of thing that
doesn't make me feel very good but I do
want to look good and when you want to
look good you got to check out geniusell
right now go to geniusell.com Knowles as
you might know we are big fans of our
friends at gen you sell I love the owner
Coptic Christian from Egypt who left for
the American dream and they got a great
product okay don't take my word for it
Ella from Rockford says quote
I have both age and acne spots this
stuff is fading both of them the serum
is worth every penny Ella is raving
about the famous Dark Spot Corrector
from genucel a must-have after months of
record heat and humidity sunspots brown
spots discoloration even red inflamed
patches all disappear in front of your
eyes here's the amazing guarantee
you will see results on day one or your
money back so take advantage of young
yourself's most popular package which
now includes the Dark Spot Corrector
plus the classic genocell bags and
puffiness treatment and immediate
effects all at about 770 off so you can
try the best skincare in the world for
yourself completely risk-free go to
genucel.com
start looking years even decades younger
tomorrow say goodbye to dark and liver
spots bags and puffiness under the eyes
grows feet geniusell.com Knowles
you don't need to take my word for it
that they're doing covet again Karine
Jean-Pierre
press secretary over at the White House
has just announced
Joe Biden is masking up President Biden
tested negative last night for kova 19
and tested negative again today he's not
experiencing any symptoms as far as the
steps he's taking since the president
was with the first lady yesterday he
will be masking while indoors and around
people in alignment with CDC guidance
and he as as has been the practice in
the past the president will remove his
mask when sufficiently distance from
others indoors and while outside as well
so we've just heard from liberal news
outlets from CNN that the masks do not
work according to scientists reported by
The Establishment journalists the mask
do not work and that's why Biden's going
to wear the mask again
what is this
just as with fauci throwing fauci to the
wolves that was a limited Hangout
a limited hangout is this this political
strategy it's often associated with the
intelligence Community where when when
you're just caught when they've just got
you dead to rights
then then you give your adversaries a
little bit
you you you chop off you know like an
infected limb you give them just a
little bit so that you can save the rest
of your body so they give them fouchy
they save the rest of the liberal
apparatus and the covid regime well
what's going on here is a similar kind
of phenomenon it's just a little test
just like with Lion's gate it was a
little test
if there's a headline that a major
company is bringing back masks
are people going to be cool with that
they're gonna some are going to
criticize but is it are we okay all
right we're going to bring it back a
little bit in Hollywood how about on
campus can we do campus again okay yeah
we'll do some random College in Atlanta
no one's ever heard of okay and we're
gonna and you know what we're even gonna
say that we're gonna have the mask for
two weeks to slow the spread they use
the exact same line just they said 14
days not two weeks 14 days to slow the
spread
okay that's I mean we'll try Rutgers
okay this is cool what if we have the
president just personally mask up is
that gonna okay
all right even it's it's in the face of
all of the scientific evidence in our
experience of the last three four years
okay now let's do it in the media news
report
Whoopi Goldberg has kovid why she even
tested for this I don't know I do know
it's because they're bringing covid back
and the political operatives are the
ones pushing this sort of thing and the
Lemmings are going along with it she
tests positive for covid they announce
it on the show here's the reaction of
the audience
as you can see Whoopi is not here she
has ID
it's back it's back but she's on the
mend she's on the tail end and she'll
probably be back this week but I'm sorry
she's not here for those of you who are
looking forward to seeing her oh no now
I don't know what impaled that reaction
it talk shows like this very often there
are lights that'll go on cheer applaud
you know that sort of thing I don't
think they put a light on I think that
was the natural reaction of the audience
okay now that's being broadcast for
everybody covid is bad initially kovid
was very scary it was gonna kill us all
then we realized kovid was was much less
dangerous than anybody suggested it was
then we found out that all the
precautions didn't really do anything
then we found out the vaccines didn't
really work and but now we're back in
the cycle now we're back to covet is
really dangerous oh no Whoopi Goldberg
has covid
she'll be back soon but
it's back
that's the announcement that's the
Declaration so now we've got it in
business we've got it in Hollywood we've
got it in the news media we've got it on
campus we've got it at the White House
most sectors of society
have have
bought back into the covet narrative and
so this will build up until the election
and it's not going to stop with the
masks and it's not going to stop with
the social distancing which was also
debunked
they want you to get another booster
shot
quick if you will who needs to get a
booster and when
all of us need boosters so if six months
of Asian up we're going to have boosters
by the end of this month hopefully and
those will protect We Believe very
strongly against these new versions of
the virus
they believe very strongly
so you know inject your six month old
with this experimental drug that didn't
do any of the things they told us it
would do didn't stop people from
Catching covet didn't stop people from
spreading covid was not nearly as safe
as they told us it was there there were
such serious side effects that they had
to shut down the vaccines for different
periods of time they had to deny the
side effects like myocarditis
pericarditis the nerve damage it's
really bad side effects blood clots
obviously in the Johnson Johnson and
others
and then it didn't work remember it
didn't actually do it so they had to
change the script they said well no the
vaccines weren't supposed to prevent you
from Catching code it was to to mitigate
the risk of death but you know look
we've all seen the tapes a million times
they told us that it was going to stop
us from Catching Cove had told us it was
going to stop us from spreading it and
then they had to change the story when
they had egg on their face but this
doctor says hey don't worry I feel
really good about this one
I feel really good
and you know what people are gonna get
it
people are going to get this stupid
booster a lot of people are going to get
it
because it's just like every other
pseudoscientific liberal political
operation
anything that happens is
said to be an argument for going along
with it
the vaccines work
oh good everybody's got to get one
the vaccines don't work well you better
get your booster
yeah because the first one didn't work
so you got to get your booster
climate change
is happening it's going to kill us all
the Earth is getting much hotter it's
really hot in the summer so
that's climate change oh it's cold
actually when it was supposed to be hot
well that's climate change too well
actually the climate hasn't really
changed all that much I know we're in
this Plateau this stasis right now
that's the evidence of climate change
you got oh there was a storm
there was a hurricane in Florida we've
never seen one of those as climate
change anything that happens anything
is taken to be evidence and and people
go along with this
because they've reached their conclusion
and they backfill the evidence and also
in this case because it's just so
politically helpful to Democrats to to
do covet in a way that it can be
politically helpful to Republicans one
because Democrats are just much better
at rigging elections by stuffing The
Ballot Box and this has been true for a
hundred years FDR and LBJ used to joke
about this
no one ever even accuses Republicans of
doing that the accusation that comes
from the Democrats is that Republicans
steal elections by kicking people off
the voter rolls
which I don't think is fair or true but
that that's the best accusation they can
make against us for rigging elections
but the accusation that we make against
them that they even joke about is that
they rig the elections by stuffing The
Ballot Box and filling up the voter
rolls with dead people with illegal
aliens with voters who have never even
seen their ballot and the other
structural reason why why the lockdowns
in the widespread mail-ins are always
going to help the Democrats more than
the Republicans is the Democrats run the
cities
it's much easier to have a political
machine in a city and two because
Democrats live in the cities and
Republicans tend to live in the country
Democrats can hit up three old age homes
and get about a bazillion ballots for
their candidate through ballot
harvesting and mail-ins in the time it
takes a republican to go to Five houses
in the country the geography is just
it's just completely different
so there is not enough time
for the Republicans to to ballot Harvest
properly
and and so because of that because it
gives the Democrats such a political
Advantage you're going to see people who
maybe they care about covid maybe that
oh maybe they just do whatever the New
York Times tells them to do they're
going to go along with it because
intuitively they know this is going to
help them
now speaking of climate change and Joy
Behar
moving off of covid for a second moving
off of
January 6th and 2024
you know they blame Trump for everything
they blame him for every little thing
that's ever happened
now they're blaming him
for the flooded Burning Man
we'll get to how that is in just one
second first though
when you want to hire really really good
people not just to run your country but
to run your company you got to check out
zip recruiter right now go to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles whether we love
it or hate it AI is here to stay and
kill us all and to just take over
civilization and well
hopefully to help the economy a little
bit maybe to avoid the Terminator
situation AI is expected to create over
100 million new jobs globally some
include data scientists product
designers robotics engineers even tax
managers with AI skills zip recruiter is
the best way to use AI to help you find
people with those skills supercruiters
AI identifies candidates who are best
suited for all kinds of roles right now
you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.comwles do you want the
most qualified candidates
ZipRecruiter uses its powerful AI not to
destroy the world but to help you and to
help your business and to build up our
economy go to ZipRecruiter right now
they let you easily invite candidates to
apply get the Leading Edge on hiring
with zip recruiter 4 out of five
employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
see for yourself go to ziprecruiter.com
for free ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
you saw that flooded burning man we
talked about it a little bit yesterday
70 000 people trapped because as a
general rule again I don't want to read
too much into it necessarily it's
generally a good idea to avoid traveling
to the desert for week-long drug-fueled
bacchanalian orgies that culminate in
the worship of a giant fiery Idol I
would just avoid that I'm not saying
you're going to get flooded out every
time you do that but it it has been
known to happen once or twice so
what's the cause of the flooding
according to the view
Donald Trump this is one of the many
tragedies this this summer uh due to
climate change this is one of those
things this is the one number one
existential problem it rained three
months worth over 24 hours but when I
hear Republicans say oh it's not
man-made it's not about fossil fuels you
know when Trump was President all of
that went up the fossil fuel usage went
up and the regulations to the planet
please don't vote for him I'm begging
you get him out of here he's so
dangerous
droughts
climate change
floods
fire
that's climate change
freeze
it's climate change
you stubbed your toe this morning
getting out of bed that's climate change
the Liberals accuse us of worshiping
Donald Trump of being an occult
Following the Leader of Donald Trump
I would never attribute the power of the
weather to Donald Trump I like the guy
obviously I admire him best president of
my lifetime
but I don't have such an outsized view
of his influence
that I attribute to him the powers of
lightning and thunder and rain in the
desert
people who attribute those god-like
powers to Donald Trump are entirely on
the left now speaking of God and burning
man Mike Lee
I just got to point out I've mentioned
it a number of times before Mike Lee is
just one of the best Senators we have
he's just one of the best politicians he
is
super smart guy he's extremely
principled he's
he comports himself in a responsible way
and is just all around a very serious
guy and
he just gets it man you know Mike Lee's
Twitter handle is based Mike Lee
and I I thought it's kind of a joke at
first I didn't actually think that it
was it was Mike but it is and
you know you think because he's buttoned
up and Mormon and a constitutional
lawyer and really polite and everything
that he's just gonna be a Wallflower or
something but he's not and especially on
social and cultural even religious
issues he digs down really deep and
doesn't doesn't back down so when the
news of burning man came out
uh Mike Lee just tweets out he goes this
is not healthy God's judgment is real
which is true fact check 100 True show
me the lie you can't do it
now what he was responding to by the way
it was not just news of the flooding it
was news of what was going on before the
flooding and this is a family show so I
can't I can't read much of this on the
air uh
this is a headline wildest Burning Man
events
no I actually can't read any of it it's
all just super
super weird sex stuff that involves like
groups of men standing around naked and
whippings and naked oil wrestling and
hypnosis circles and man I am cleaning
this up so much that you probably have
no idea what I'm talking about you can
go read it at the Daily Star
this is
really depraved decadent stuff and the
thing that's most striking about it is
not that weirdos will go to the desert
and do weird drugs and sex stuff
it's that according to the elite if you
go to this according to the elite if you
drive out to the middle of the desert
and do a ton of drugs and have all sorts
of weird orgies with people of both
sexes and everything in between and then
worship a giant burning Idol and then go
home after nine days you are cultured
and sophisticated you're really you're
avant-garde you you want you you're
Progressive you're thinking ahead of all
those Rubes
and if you go to church you're in a cult
and if you vote for a republican you're
an occult you're a weirdo you're totally
crazy
hypnosis naked oil wrestling daily
whippings in the desert
posh
you know that's just what the elites do
that's just what we do
you remember
it was Dominic Strauss Khan
was that big Financial marketing muck
this was now we're going back like 20
years but it was the it was the first
one of these guys in my lifetime who was
one of the big you know the people at
the big institutions like the IMF or the
UN or the WTO or these big massive
institutions who got caught doing really
weird sex stuff
and and his defense was oh no I don't go
to that many orgies you know I know I
don't go to this man and then the story
came out during the hunter Biden
investigation that there's this really
Elite
sex club in La maybe it's in New York
too with movie stars and politicians and
all do you remember Madison cawthorne he
basically got run out of Congress for
blowing the whistle on eyes wide shot
parties in our nation's capital
you know the home of our sacred Temple
of democracy the most most pristine
light of democracy ever in the history
of the world and and then of course it
was Jeffrey Epstein when we found out
that
the supposedly conspiratorial Q Anon
whatever theory that the elites run this
underage sex ring is not only not a
conspiracy theory but they've got their
own Island and it involves not only
elected heads of state but also members
of the royal family and also huge
Business Leaders and
it's all it's all real it's it's it's
difficult for me to even wrap my head
around it now having seen all of the
evidence for years and years and years
now
I guess that's just the way it works in
this world because the devil is the
prince of this world and we struggle not
against flesh but against principalities
and powers and spiritual wickedness in
high places
and in that world we talked about a book
Yesterday by the Italian General Roberto
Fibonacci called the world upside down
in that upside down world if you go do
weird bakanaian drug orgy idol worship
stuff in the desert
you're you're normal it's like and if
you just have a normal family and you go
to church and you're crazy it's like the
monsters you remember the Monsters TV
show I'm really dating myself
as a millennial who watched reruns in
the 90s on Nick at night but in The
Munsters you got all these crazy
monsters who are in the family and this
one hot blonde girl and the hot blonde
girl thinks that she's ugly because her
environment is such that she's
surrounded by monsters all the time and
so her perception is that she's the
abnormal one she and that's that's how I
think us conservatives that's how we
feel now
I think am I crazy am I the crazy one
because I don't go to the word she's in
the desert Maybe
according to the wisdom of this world I
guess I am speaking of faith
faith in college education has
completely collapsed in the United
States
public opinion polls about 10 13 years
ago
all had the same story and the story was
Americans believe in college
86 percent of college graduates around
2010 2012.
said that college had been a good
investment
another survey said 74 of young adults
viewed college education as very
important a third one said 60 of
Americans in total across the board said
colleges and universities were having a
positive impact on the country
in 2009 this was right around the time I
went to college little I went to college
in 2008.
70 percent of high school graduates
went straight to college
seventy percent that was an all-time
high in American history
and this was heralded as a wonderful
thing
now the trend is totally reversed and I
think that that's a much better thing
now
the percentage of young adults who said
college degree is very important has
gone from 74 to 41 a third of Americans
say they have confidence in higher
education among Zoomers 45 almost half
of Zoomers say a high school diploma is
all you need to ensure Financial
Security
and
almost half of American parents say they
don't want their kid to go to college
a total collapse how did that happen
well what the Liberals will say is this
this is backsliding this is regressive
this is the consequence of the
anti-intellectual Trump era in which
Trump brazenly said that he loves the
uneducated we're just going to hell in a
handbasket uh
no no I don't think that's quite the
story I think the story is
that you can't hide a fraud forever
even the best con artist in the world
can't hide his crimes forever
of eventually Bernie Madoff is going to
get caught and the colleges are Bernie
Madoff it's been a complete racket
what what these colleges and the
apparatchics in government who boosted
these colleges by underwriting all of
the loans that allowed the tuitions to
Skyrocket what they promised was that if
you come here
you send your kid here your kid is going
to turn out better
and the initial promise the real promise
of a liberal education in the good sense
of the word liberal is that you learn to
make sense of your freedom and you steep
yourself in the culture of your
civilization and you you learn how to
think about abstract things and then you
can go on and get job training and have
a good career then when that didn't
materialize the the pitch for college
became hey come here and you'll get a
good job which was never what university
education was about it was never about
job training at all but they realized
okay well we're obviously not teaching
our kids to think in an abstract way the
standards that the colleges have
absolutely created so okay well don't
worry you're at least going to get a job
this is a credential that you need to
get a good high-paying job and then
that kind of crater too
now kids go and and all the while by the
way the cost has gone up to now what a
quarter million dollars to get a
four-year college degree at some places
and what's the payoff
there is no payoff you don't get any
intellectual or spiritual payoff you
don't even get a financial payoff it's
just a big scam oh and by the way your
kids come out of college hating you
because the college spends four years
undoing everything that you spent 18
years trying to instill into your
children
and because of the way our economy works
now you probably didn't get a whole ton
of time to spend with your children
because it's very hard to raise a family
on one income so both parents now
usually have to work so the kids end up
getting raised by by daycare workers and
by public school teachers from the age
of it used to be five now it's really
from the age of three or even two I have
friends who have two-year-olds they say
I'm sending my kid to school now to at
the age of Two And so you've already got
such an uphill battle
and then the colleges come and finish it
off and the parents and the students are
saying enough what's the benefit for
this is the conservative consolation
which is
things are really bad and they might get
worse and they might get even worse than
that
but reality reasserts itself eventually
in the end it has to you can't it is not
possible to deny reality
forever now speaking of political
realities we've got some new poll
numbers out on the 24 presidential race
and
you know I hate to say I told you so but
I told you so we'll get to that in one
second first though my favorite comment
yesterday is from Steven arapato who
says Burning Man describes the STDs
everyone leaves with so true
maybe maybe Burning Man was the friends
we made along the way those friends were
veterial diseases very true
we're talking about poll numbers let's
turn to 2024
is a poll published by The Wall Street
Journal showing that Donald Trump is now
the top choice of 59 of GOP Primary
voters
this is up 11 percentage points since
April
according to the journal the new survey
finds what was once a two-man race for
the nomination has collapsed into a
lopsided contest in which Trump for now
has no formidable Challenger I know that
this is going to upset people who are
campaigning for Ron DeSantis
I really like Ron DeSantis I've gotten
to spend a little bit of time with him
very impressed with the guy I think he's
a terrific Governor admire him greatly
I have noticed maybe this was inevitable
some campaigners for Ron DeSantis are
shooting the messenger here because
these numbers are not not looking great
and people are conflating two different
types of discussion of the 2024 race
the descriptive discussion and the
prescriptive discussion so I've made
clear unlike some of my friends and
colleagues and I guess basically
everybody in conservative media I have
no interest in endorsing anybody in this
race
I like both of these guys I like Donald
Trump a lot I like Rhonda santis a lot I
think they got thick skin I think they
can duke it out I like primaries I like
when conservatives toughen each other up
there are other candidates too Vivek
obviously a friend of mine and and other
candidates as well
it it seems to me from the beginning
simply a descriptive fact
that it's been Trump's race from the
beginning that all of the factors here
not the least of which is this is the
first time since 1892 that we have had a
president running for non-consecutive
second term that it was always Trump's
race
and so I'm I've been pointing this out
and I've been pointing out also some
flaws I think with the DeSantis campaign
things that are not helping DeSantis
from I want to be very clear here I'm
not casting a moral judgment on the
DeSantis campaign or on the Trump
campaign
sometimes people have written it and
said Michael why why don't you call out
the Trump campaign for all the mean
nasty awful things they're doing
because I'm not talking about mean nasty
awful things period
I'm I'm not if I were to lambast a
campaign as a as a matter of a moral
judgment that would be a tantamount to
making an endorsement I'm not doing that
I'm describing the campaign tactics
from the perspective of their efficacy
in the campaign and it is an
indisputable fact that the the Santa's
campaign has not been effective and I
think there are specific things that
they have done that have harmed their
campaign I think they've shot themselves
in the foot in some ways but even beyond
that I think that the circumstances of
the race have been such that
it was always going to be a long shot
and it's not that he's out of the race
yet it's not that the race is totally
over but 59 is a pretty crazy number it
means the entire GOP field could drop
out other than one guy and it still
wouldn't be close
that is if that fact drives you crazy
then you've got to stop paying attention
to politics unless you're an active
campaign worker you got to stop paying
if that if it drives you crazy to watch
politics happen to watch primary
campaigns
take place and occur in the ups and the
downs and that then find another hobby
you can't there's no you're not going to
affect the race in any way you're just
gonna pull your hair out it's like
watching a baseball game and screaming
at the TV and thinking that if you rub
your head and Pat your belly then you
know Derek Jeter is going to hit a home
run that's that's not going to happen
you're you're only you're not going to
change the outcome of the game you're
only going to upset yourself
the Trump campaign has been effective
the DeSantis campaign has not been
effective if DeSantis wants to turn this
around before the Iowa caucuses DeSantis
has to radically change his campaign
and even then it might not work because
I I again I don't even really blame the
campaign or DeSantis that much I just
think the circumstances are such that
this is a primary unlike any we've ever
seen But if DeSantis wants to have a
shot he has got to radically change his
campaign
59 man that is a really big number now
turning to the other party
there is another potential candidate in
the race no I'm not talking about Bobby
Kennedy no I'm not talking about
Marianne Williamson
I'm talking about
old father time himself the man who has
run for office consistently since what
just like Joe Biden actually same same
year Biden got elected I'm talking about
Bernie Sanders
the president has a right to be very
proud of many of the accomplishments
that we've achieved in the last three
years unemployment very very low we
brought inflation down we're investing
in clean energy we're rebuilding our
infrastructure uh we have made real
progress in a number of areas but
the reality is that today
sixty percent of our people living
paycheck to paycheck we have massive
levels of income and wealth inequality
three people or more wealth in the
bottom half of America our Health Care
system is a total disaster 85 million
people uninsured uninsured underinsured
while the insurance companies make huge
profits the cost of pharmaceutical drugs
prescription drugs Sky High
Bernie Sanders traveling up to New
Hampshire
delivering a speech called the agenda
America needs Bernie Sanders
has been running for office since 1972.
is it really so crazy to think he might
run again
why not the two leading candidates okay
the leading candidate for each party
right now is rather elderly a gentleman
of a certain age and Bernie's been
running his whole life consistently
since 1972.
he ran for nine years for starting in
1972 he didn't even get elected to
anything until 1981 he becomes mayor of
Burlington 10 years later elected to
congress 15 16 years later he gets
elected to the Senate runs for president
the last two times why wouldn't he run
now plus
in a way the wind is at Bernie's back
because he was one of the early populist
candidates don't forget Bernie for all
of his wickedness and from racing
socialism which is an evil ideology and
completely unacceptable for any
conservative or Christian certainly to
to embrace
Bernie was not just a lockstep Democrat
Bernie was not his anti-gun as most
Democrats but he changed a little bit in
the presidential campaigns but he wasn't
his anti-gun because he's from Vermont
and he was pretty strongly
anti-immigration
because Bernie's an old school economic
populist and and he recognizes that that
mass migration is is a scam it's a scam
by the left to increase their voter
numbers but it's a scam by the business
right the Chamber of Commerce type right
to lower wages for the working class so
Bernie being a working class fighter at
least in his own mind he was he was
opposed to immigration but he's kind of
been dethroned as a populist he made
populism his whole career and then Trump
came in and ate his lunch and now in the
Democrat Party uh Bobby Kennedy is
probably taking that that lane as well
now all of this leads up to a potential
government shutdown in DC and usually in
these circumstances it's the
conservatives who want to shut down the
government the liberals who want to keep
the government operating
this time though the situation might be
flipped
and that will be my little tease for
tomorrow I'm sorry look I don't mean to
tease you
but there's only so much time okay and
we have to get to member block today is
woke Wednesday we are combining woke
Wednesday with
the Tuesday show which is of an ideology
that I cannot name on YouTube because we
moved that Tuesday show of the ideology
that I can't name on YouTube to
today after music Monday moved to
Tuesday it's Labor Day really messed up
a lot of this week the show continues
now you do not want to miss it become a
member use code Knowles Canada WLS check
out for two months free on all annual
plans
[Music]